we have a right circular cone with a
shaded base and we will try to derive a
formula for the surface area of a cone
let us name the points or a/b points a
and B are marked on the circumference
such that a B forms a diameter let L be
the slant height and H be the
perpendicular height and let R be the
radius of the circular base first let us
consider the circular base the radius of
the circular base is R so it's area will
be PI R squared next we need to find the
area of the curved surface and we have
seen that when the curved surface is
opened up it looks like a sector we also
need to find the area of the sector let
the sector be OAB
look at the sector and the cone what do
you think is the measure of these two
lengths Oh a and OB will equal the slant
height which is L here's another
interesting question what will be the
length of Arc a B this is an arc as we
know that a sector is part of a circle
this arc is actually the circumference
of the circular base so the length of
this arc will be 2 PI R a sector is also
defined by the angle it subtends at the
center let us call it theta now we are
ready to find the area of the sector and
it gets even more interesting there is
another way in which we can find the
length of the arc a B let's zoom out to
look at the other way it will equal
theta by 360 multiplied by the
circumference of the circle with radius
or a and OB what will be the
circumference of the circle that is
formed with this as the sector it will
be 2 pi L since L is the radius of the
circle of which this sector is a part
this tells us that the length of Arc a B
is a part of the circumference of the
big circle that can be formed here but
the length of Arc a B is also 2 PI R
that will equal theta by 360 multiplied
by 2 pi L canceling 2 pi out from both
sides we get R equal to theta by 360
multiplied by L the area of this sector
will be the curved surface area of this
cone the area of this sector will equal
theta by 360 multiplied by the area of
the circle with o a and OB as the radius
and that will be PI l squared as L is
the radius of this circle can we write
this a bit differently yes
this can also be written as pi L
multiplied by theta by 360 multiplied by
L we have just split by l squared into
pi L multiplied by L but this part in
brackets as which is found out is equal
to R so the curved surface area will be
PI L multiplied by R let us review what
we just did we found out the length of
Arc a B in two different ways and
equated them and then we found out the
curved surface area using the formula of
a sector of a circle and then finally
substituted the value of R in this
formula to eliminate theta now it's very
simple the total surface area of the
code will be the curved surface area
plus the area of the circular base the
curved surface area as we know is PI L R
and the area of the base is PI R squared
both the terms have PI R as the common
factor taking PI are common we write the
formula as pie R multiplied by L plus R
this is the formula for the total
surface area of a right circular cone
you